[Music]
hi guys thanks everyone who's here
tonight for
end game lecture
i'm a grand master alex shabolov
current german residence at saint louis
chess club
and my lecture today about how to
convert an exo exchange in endgame
not very original lecture i
took materials from
russian magazine 64.
i'm using
all the materials from there
i remember when i saw this piece a
couple of years ago it was like really
uh
not a shocking thing but like how you
can actually be
a grandmaster all your life but
do not hear those simple things actually
being put into words and and see how
how they work so i
i really want
i want to share it with you tonight okay
one simple rule that capablanca pointed
out in one of his books
basically
what is the advantage of a rook over
uh knight and bishop
and
what do you think
right i mean
it's not enough to say that rook is just
going
uh
files like back and forth and pieces are
like for example like a bishop goes
diagonals and there are as many squares
i guess
uh
most of the bishop
like a standard bishop move covers as
many squares as a
typical rook move
so what is an advantage in the in the
end game
of the rook over bishop for example
with the knight is kind of it's more or
less clear um because well knight is a
short-range piece it's uh
it operates well in the closed
structures
it can go places where neither rook or
bishop can go
right uh
but
rook versus bishop is a little bit
different okay there are a lot of
positions where there are simply
pieces of the same power and uh
like it's really hard to make a
difference okay between this
two so kappa blanca was the first guy
who actually pointed out
um
no yeah overall but not on a even uh
rook can access the whole board but not
on a uh
any single uh on a
current move when
any current move i think it's just
pretty much yeah go ahead
oh
it's going
i'm just gonna offer another guess
okay yes
they can
kind of restrict the king better by
blocking off okay
sometimes bishop can do that too you
know just cut the diagonal where the
king can go to
so
no that's that's true yeah so i mean
bishop cannot on on his own cannot
really restrict the king from going
wherever he wants
yeah but uh cava blanca pointed out the
main advantage and the main advantage is
that the rook
at all times
can
trade for the bishop and not the other
way around
the rook can attack the bishop and if it
needs to
i can take it um and this is why by the
way the bishop is better than the knight
in the most open positions that uh
bishop most of the time can be traded
for the knight and not the other way
around
okay
if if you're playing with the bishop
versus the knight there uh the common
method of playing it you keeping bishop
outside of the knights range so if the
black has knight on d5
your bishop is somewhere around the
second rank you know d2 or e2 it's like
that kind of thing so the main advantage
and uh
is that
the side with the rook
can always convert to winning on ending
okay
versus the other way around
it looks like a simple rule and there's
nothing to be explained but we're going
to look at the examples today
that are not that simple we'll see how
pretty strong grandmaster were missing
opportunities because of not following
the simple rule and so on okay so let's
start with the game uh
uh
anarchy of versus solac
anarchy of very well-known russian
masters like
20 i mean getting close to 2700 or even
being there for and then just dropping
back a little bit but that's the range
650 to 2700
for last
i don't know 15 years something like
that
okay
and dragons saw like a
super strong
grandmaster well is it slovenia i would
guess
but uh not hundred percent sorry but
um okay
so let's look at the game
uh
no interesting uh chebanenko sloth
so-called with a6
it's a serbia by the way serbia okay
yeah
uh
yeah that would be my second guess
all right so knight e4
bsn b2 e6
knight c3 no opening is interesting but
it's not really our concern
uh
get into the end game with extra pawn
for white but
but
it's really hard to win
opposite color bishops and after c5
no of course if white doesn't want to
lose i mean he's not going to lose the
same game just
but
well
in our kiev is the very ambitious player
and feels like
two points for the exchange and the
strong bishop on c4 cover and all the
scores should be enough for a win
and
now it's actually three points so
definitely should be enough for a win
until
it wasn't
okay
white did something wrong position was
of course winning and
black defended really well
and at some point white simply overstep
the
this line would like the risk was
acceptable they didn't want to draw
okay and
what happened they got into
found themselves into the lost time game
bishop b4
okay rook b4 king e3
all right
black to move what would you do here
if that's your game yeah go ahead
okay
well
rook takes bishop is a winning move and
seems like there is nothing more
simple than that right takes
takes keen takes and with a simple play
kings comes over and picks up both pawns
there's nothing white can do
so the question is
why in the world such a strong
player as a solo
didn't do it
why like uh
why even to consider an xml was he
probably was thinking that if he
if he doesn't take on e4 it's still a
winning position
but
it would be a direct contradiction to a
couple blocker rule
so why even
considering it
okay
hold on a second let's see how the game
ended
so one more time
this time together with the finish
yeah white obviously should not like
ever
be close to losing this position but
that's what happened instead of rook
takes e4
2600 grand master
takes and
i don't know probably of thinking that
this is winning even though
frankly i don't i don't see what exactly
he missed because the
e6 pawn cannot be protected and uh
maybe he thought bishop takes c6 rook
takes e5 as force but uh
again this is uh
just not checkers and you don't have to
take on e6 it's enough to defend the
point
and
simple
draw can give four and
there we go
okay that was a
first one first example
so the second one is
shapiroka vs gruenfeldt uh the game from
1925
of
these two guys you probably know aaron's
gruntfelt
better than the white player
even though
chess wise i think the
shapiroko was kind of stronger
but
the famous defense was named after grand
master grunfeld and gruenfeldt
and
okay anyways let's go quickly go to the
position in question
are we going to be on the white side so
let me
switch to flipboard
do you uh want the notation out there
oh no i can close it sorry yeah
i forgot that this is resizes board yeah
i don't need it
so
no the game itself was uh
i know how fascinating it was like a
black pretty quickly
allowed white to win on exchange for
nothing by the way
and
no for current grand masters that would
be
a straightforward conversion but
well it did not happen in this game and
for some reason
both sides were okay with a lot of
exchanges and still
still very surprising that you know
uh
no everyone knows that uh you're in the
rook versus knight you don't trade
coincide pawns right you don't the only
chance for black to
make a draw if the pawns are on the one
side of the board if they're on both
sides of the board the knight there's
nothing knight can do against the rope
but let's see how easily white just
trades both
pawns
on a queen side
it's just like a
ridiculous iron out
but anyways
[Music]
pretty soon
we do arrive yep we arrive into position
and black doesn't even tries not to
trade rooks
which is like
just shows us how confident
grundfold was that the
white will never convert it but okay
finally
decided to
trade rookie five
here we go
and
so let's go to the position that's going
to be in question the maneuvers
maneuvers circuit c5
and 95.
okay
so this would be our starting position
and i would ask you like how what do you
think is the plan
to convert this advantage right okay so
let me just
go to
this position one more time
and this time it's going to be
with the moves so
back here turn attention
roxy five
knight d3
king of 6 67
rook c5 93
okay here we go
so the first thing that we see is that
uh well it's rook versus knight
black has two disconnected points
like how is that even
could possibly be a problem right to
convert this
but what happens those pawns and the
knight create a barrier for the king to
come in
and in order to come in we need to trade
one of the pawns
once it won against one
it becomes very tricky
okay
and
there are a lot of the drawing position
it's very easy to come across some
fortress or something like this
but
shapiroka i
demonstrated a very very
precise way to convert this one and
let's try to do it together
okay
hi guys
yeah good evening everyone who
was not here at the beginning
all right we
looking at the ways to convert on
extra exchange in the ending according
to capablanca
uh
okay interesting guess rook takes c5 but
see if it works so rook takes e5
kin takes
no king g4 king f6
this probably would not work because of
king of five right
and that's it a four king of four
actually white has to be careful now and
would like not to lose this one
um
okay
and if you go like e4
it's here
e5 king h6
it's no way to break through
so yes we can know the second exchange
but
black is not going to give you the pawn
so easily
so
let's play it on
it looks like a very very simple task
let's see if you'll be up to it
what do you think a starting move white
was trying to get the same position with
black to move he already did
but the problem is on the rook a5 we got
knight c4 and then knight comes back
and now
triangulation is not that easy because
you go king g2 i'll go knight c4
and then you go king of two
knight e5 and king g3
that's interesting
that actually that maybe
that sounds like an interesting way to
go
okay
yeah king g2 is a great suggestion just
triangulate with a kink with uh
just king g2
knight c4 come here and there we go same
position with the block to move
problem however is this move
okay and
well we gotta deal with the pawn on
e3
and if we go e4 knight comes back
so what y did he actually really wanted
this position to be on the board
and
okay let me just go back yeah
so 95 and uh supercar started with a
move e4
already
what's the idea now knight has to go
right
knight's going away and then we play in
king g4
and when we play in king g4 95 checks no
longer possible because then we
sacrifice and take a pawn on g5
so knight f7
next move
if we go
kin
so we went king g4 and kin g6 uh
no knight h5s it does not work i mean as
soon as the king
gets in i mean black is done right it's
a simple two swank check
here here and now
all white needs to do it just wait
through k5 for example
and that's it black loses material and
loses
everything
so
but king g6
okay
right here it turns out that there are
if you go e5 right now well then knight
h6 kicks the king out
king gets to f5 and what after knight f7
white will be losing the pawn e5
uh waiting does not help because knight
h6 check and comes back
so
this is the moment where
white goes
f4
takes takes
and
most important moment is that we have e5
check after king f6 if not for that move
it could easily be a draw
so
king f6
no other moves like
knight d6 rook b6
knight h6 king e5 everything else loses
but after this one
on
we go e5
king goes to e7
and now there is a trickiest part
so
this position can only be won by kappa
block a row
which means you should not even like uh
always should have it on the back of
your mind that to win and maneuver will
be sacrificing rook for the night there
is no other way to win it
you cannot
get the keep bring the king on f6
without like a
black operation
but if you'll do it right away uh rook
b7 here
takes takes no it's obvious draw right
opposition
so basically you need to get this
position with the black to move
and for this
what's the next move for white
so again the task right now is that we
are trying to win a position in the pawn
ending
um how does it help if like you're
playing rook a5 and i go like no i know
king e8 for example
okay king g4
diego
absolutely correct keen g4
this move creates a thread
see what happens if i like uh the thread
right now is rook b7 exchange king takes
and then we win in the opposition by
playing king h5
diagonal opposition that is a very
important
black played no cake you played king d7
in the game but uh no there's no there's
no chance if knight moves king comes in
and then check on seven king goes to f6
uh if king stays
like with the knight
then
check doesn't matter where it goes pin
next move takes and king h5
so
that this is the win now in the game
this is what happened king h5 white wins
uh
probably not unused for a lot of players
but uh i must admit that uh
uh i never
i've seen it presented in such a like
simple and uh
visual ways like the winning technique
of a rock against the lighter piece
so you're always looking to like
liquidate into upon ending there's
simply there are a lot of position rook
versus knight there is no other way to
do it okay
so
again
winning technique and here is to
win the opposition and upon ending and
that's what you have to look for that
and king g4 is the simplest way
uh to do this because after the kink
we'll take the rook on f7 we need move
king h5
okay
all right let's keep going
so next game
next game is rishevsky versus mislove
and the famous
uh
usa versus the soviet union radio match
in 1945
uh a lot of people know this match as
the
kind of
i don't even know how to call it it's
the match where the uh batwinnick played
but
he's famous between croatian and uh slav
defense
for the first time ever
against danker
and uh
on board one and
uh
no well
it's historical match and just like
historical for many many reasons
and this is the game from that match
uh we're gonna be looking at from the
black's point of view
okay
by the way pretty modern line
e3
yep allowing
bishop to take on c4
and now black is quietly prepared for c5
and when he
finally plays c5 this pawn on b4 will
give him a space advantage so it's
white cannot play so
um
you know
so calm like krishevsky did in this game
he gets worse
c5 no
pretty clear for every
slav player that black is already
looking for the advantage here his
pieces are much better and plus space
advantage okay f3 great idea
by rashevsky to
claim the
space advantage back but smith love
already starts
tactical operations and
somewhere around here he wins on
exchange after
this beautiful
tactical shot no okay well
sammy was
always an optimist and
you know just continues to play through
and surprising
oh yeah sorry it's just like yeah for
some reason in in a database uh
that's how the game is recorded with 24
at this point which is obviously is not
was not played in the game but uh
queen went somewhere else
on e-file i'm just not sure but but i'm
just using the game from a chess base if
if we forget about this queen e4
the rest of it is uh
pretty fine so i
must say that it's of course
later on his careers mislove was very
famous for
impeccable technique and everything but
not in this game
black position is completely winning but
he allows it to
become
more complicated than it should have
been yeah for example oh yeah no just
define 92.
so king f1
takes takes
and pretty soon we're going to be coming
to
bg3 knight f4
and kin takes b3
so
is that that's it yep
and it's black to move
okay
and
i don't know if you were playing this
position with black pieces like
before our lecture today
would the reaction be the same would you
be like looking at the
i know no it doesn't really look like a
joy just because bishops are holding all
the pawns for a second right it's just
it's not really the but uh and probably
just the king move king to c5 and then
some knight maneuvers
would do the job
okay
but
it goes against kappa blanca's rule
and what this couple blocker rule tells
us to do here exactly
yeah instead this is not an instinctive
sack if you don't know the rule i mean
that's absolutely correct you will be
looking in the
game like king c5 looks great like king
c3 then i know 96
you try to re-maneuver the knights like
somewhere and try to win it like without
any sacrifice but it just incorrect
instinct the instinct should be
to sacrifice and convert to the
winning
pawn ending and this is what's miss love
does
let's see
let's play it all over again to the same
position
rook takes c4
pawn takes king comes after
uh
rusevski decides to trade one of the
pawns but the problem is that black has
two
if
g7 pawn was not on the board well that
would be a draw
but
two pawns
it's enough like uh two pawns are
winning
one will cost uh white the bishop and
the other will be quitting so
uh
no there is not much of a
no i but still i like like the for
example rushevsky like plays king e5 a
clear trap what's miss love playing
knight d3 you know and pick up the
bishop
or not no answer of course yet
not
so g4
uh
no i don't know i would i would try to
do oh well no g3
the pawn will always be protected by
you know moving it to g6 g3 wins on the
spot resets can resign after g4
didn't play king of five
so
next one
oh
yeah that was his rusevski's last trap
night fork and king goes to
pick up pick up the pawns yeah you have
to play g4 but that already might
complicate the matters and then next no
i mean probably still no it's still
winning yeah of course
uh if you'll go g4
but
i don't think
smurfslove like it was nothing fair i i
think there was nothing fancy about this
match in the
back in soviet union that was like
considered like you know
matter of national pride though he would
not play knight d3 okay g4
so the a lot of people would have a
heart attack if he'll do it
all right so
yeah let's keep going
next one is
okay no this is super famous game two
i think a lot of you
i know that but
it's pretty interesting to look at it in
this new context okay as a
exchange sacrifice as the way to convert
the advantage the game itself very well
known
uh is semi-slot playable for
[Music]
well i mean there's nothing wrong with
the opening it's one of the most
fascinating opening in chess
so
whether you're 2100 or 1500
it's a great it's a fantastic opening
it's a
if you're thinking that it might be
over to too complicated for 2100 player
no not at all
um
it's great
i as i always saying like every player
should have in his repertoire one
classical opening
and one
modern opening against both e4 and d4 no
and of course against c4 and knight f3
as well
so sloth is one of those classical
openings where the black does not yield
in the center
and slot goes well with witch openings
uh
i think
like uh
language dutch comes to mind uh
the norni
maybe
okay
king's indian is not really a modern
opening uh
like bangkok okay
yeah sloth and banco that's a great
combination
you've got like the best of boards
worlds and it depends on your mood if
you're like a feel solid you go for a
sloth if not you go for bangkok
something like this
so yeah
semi sloth
no no it's not masters if you think it's
massive territory because there's a lot
of theory
no like any other openings it can be
played by simple understanding what
you're doing
uh of course you can go into
will wilderness of the botvinni creation
and mosque operation but you don't have
to there are a lot of quiet uh lines
quiet lines in slab
for example this chabanenko sloth is
pretty quiet when you can play uh
literally without knowing any theory
okay
no anyways
so lombardi fisher
f3 knight c6 c4 e6
bishop p7 bishop e3 knight c2 is a
little too much
on bishop e2 and according to
modern views
it should be better for white
but uh
knight c2 no idea of 92 is pretty clear
lombardi really thought that
d5 is a
d5 is a threat and why why am i thinking
it's not a threat
after bcp2
i don't know
maybe d5 is a threat
okay anyway so knight c2 d5
fisher sacrifices a pawn anyway
and plays queen c7
so
very very modern uh concept
there are a lot of openings currently
just to
follow in this concept
the most
noticeable is a
taras
when d5 c4 is
c4 e6 and
knight c3
c5 became like really popular on the top
grandmaster level
idea is just to
i don't take and
like
take again
and it's like a
oh
of course no i'm sorry so
first of course this
like knight c6
and then well we can take take and
queen goes somewhere you know and then
bishop e6 development
well i'm sure the fisher was playing his
ga his gambit for for a win uh
modern grandmaster is doing the
target for for a draw
so
nevertheless
black winning an exchange quickly
uh
here it's for a pawn no one is not
enough compensation for
foreign exchange here knight b4
takes takes
rook d5
h4 king e6
can get three and rook goes to
c8 i've seen an analysis in the in in
the books and like dedicated to fisher i
don't remember if any of the of those
analysis was here
oh consensus is it's like a pretty much
every move
that does not allow what happened in the
game is a draw like uh
like i know f4 or root goes to like
anywhere but e file
uh
sorry a file oops
i'm clicking on something which is not
yeah rookie one
and here's simple right the
fisher
i don't know if he knew carpe blanco's
rule but if you don't know it
you might
think it like that
might be ways to
win this position without sacrifice like
go maybe h6 g5 and then f4 and then
somehow like a
maneuver your rook so that they were
coming in
but if you know the rule you will not
even
waste your time on doing that so
and fisher didn't
immediately went for
liquidation
however he had to calculate the pawn
ending but
i mean there's not much to it after a5
it's
kind of very clear
a pawn will be traded for c pawn and
then everything on the king side will be
fallen
no
yeah
okay
so fission knew the rule and now you do
two
so
next one
load next game
oh here we come capablanca himself
against ziyanovsky
1916.
so let's see how the
no
the wrong one just flipboard
why am i like
clicking on enter or something
okay anyway so
let's see how capablanca converted it
himself
so
pretty interesting
but not much to yeah you would even
think that black is slightly better here
it's that's probably the case
but uh here we go
rook c4
um
no i don't know what it is is that
arrogance or miscalculation or whatever
capablanca is white
and david yanovsky is black
so now you probably know about the
rivalry between these two players what
was going on all their lives
despite the presence of alekhine but uh
well anyways
v3 and black loses on exchange and i
don't even know like what was the
maybe he thought that this is enough
compensation maybe that was his way to
play for a win
uh i can only guess like what is
clearly
the despite like great standing pieces
knight on d5 and uh
perfect pawn structure
black cannot really play it for a win
so after more exchanges
capablanca started doing what he's
supposed to do which is to create a
passer on a king site where he has four
against three
for an explicable reason the yanovsky
copyrights he just helped him out i mean
i don't think on his own there would be
such an easy job for cappa blanca but
you know
uh
black simply
was every move he helps out and just
h4 yep it's very very consistent with
what he's doing
and that was his trademark in the
endgame yeah see every move is just
like by modern standard every black move
last 10 moves is just a bad mistake just
for the reason because with every move
he helps
white to clear the board on a king's
side and create a passer
and like
no what can you say here
the looks nice tactical move g5 cannot
be taken but uh
once white
defense against this threat well
what it did is just to
help him out
it did help him out to
king g2
right
so this is the position
our starting position for this example
for
capoblanca converting himself and let me
just go to
the one
that has moves after this okay
check
oh
yeah i was supposed to start to
give you this position on the right side
i went one move further but i think it's
already not uh
not a secret
to what white was
was is supposed to do here okay
so
if you think that this position could be
one
without sacrifices just maybe go rookie
5 and then get another rook on f5
uh
kick this bishop out and then try to go
for g5 bring the king over and
maybe
okay
i think it's doable
but you got to be super precise
you got to be super precise you like uh
those knight forks night jumps are
possible the
you have to look out the v3 pawn is not
never attacked and the black cannot
activate
uh
he yeah his pawns let's start pushing
them forward capablanca eliminates all
of this counter play in a
simple and understandable maneuver
rookie 5 attacks the bishop
and after bishop f6 absolutely zero
hesitation it's just like takes
okay it
by now it should be pretty obvious to
you like why why he did it uh that
eliminates black's counter play and now
it's just whether or not black will be
able to stop g point
and there is
no single indication like
why he
possibly can do that because
white pawn will be helped by rook bishop
andy king
and the black
cannot say the same thing so he picks up
yet another one
uh why he okay he can't go to c6 because
rook d6 check yeah
the rook defense so picks up one on b4
takes takes
that also that that's actually great
insight i mean
uh
if i didn't know this game
would i play rook d6
in the game
i'm not sure probably not i would
probably try to push the
jeep on us to g6 and
try to bring my king over and try to win
that like
but
well that's why they saying capo blanca
was on game genius and uh
his intuition
tells him rook d6 winning
and it is
yeah
uh technique is
fantastic again
bishop f4 we have a four display that
the black king cannot come over
and then
jeep one used as a deflection obviously
we cannot promote it the black king in
front of it no capablanca tried i don't
know no i don't think he tried he just
put black king as a
maximum like passive position
and then g6
bishop g7 king d5
so what happens right now
uh
that black is going to trade b pawn for
a g point
this way
and the question after that would
obviously be
would black be able to
give up the bishop for a pawn or not
and the answer is
not
uh
oh yeah okay
i'm sorry yeah i'm
i
i don't want to give you an impression
that this is uh
this is a win and end game i think here
uh
that this game is famous for
for the fact that yanovsky resign in
equal position
okay
so
king f5 and yeah king d5 and he resigned
and i think it's in dwarveski book that
he explained that
[Music]
the black king should go behind the pawn
and should save the day for
so i think after king of four it's
technically a draw
yeah but i don't want to bother you with
the
with the
lines uh
this defense that king comes from behind
and
uh not only from behind but he should go
to uh
the pawn from the other side of like if
white king is on c6 black king has to be
like on uh a4 or something like this
there are some rules but uh i believe
instead of uh resigning here can get
four would be a draw
okay anyways let's keep going
um
no
court snoy versus serper
this
two
very interesting personalities from the
chess world
uh
victor on
diet
already uh
gregory serper that comes to the united
states around the same time i did
in the beginning of uh
beginning of uh
1990s
okay
and it happened after
the uzbek team
absolutely uh
gloriously took a silver at the olympiad
in manila where
serper was a part of that team
because he came and he was very active
for
for a long time
and then
retired early became
like a day trader or whoever but still i
mean very interesting chess articles on
many platforms
very interesting comments i'm sure he's
remained a
very strong player
but just without any wish to play on but
uh
when
serper
was leading that was back team to a
silver
at the
olympia in
1992
he was for a while he was receiving a
lot of invitations from the top
international tournaments and well
i think those were his best years
anyway so let's go
and
was a tremendous defender i mean like uh
saved so many difficult positions and
here no you can tell chords noise
pushing
but
b sub g4
bishop d7
and somewhere around here
black is forced yeah to take on d7
otherwise
white kink will take on g4
eventually like we'll come over to to to
help the pawn on d7 and so that was
for some reason it was the last moment
where black could have done it take
stakes and
take on
d8 and
play it king f5
no and
this is the position that where we are
starting with
right and
no the this
the wind here is easy
because
black bishop is just overloaded he's a
he cannot defend b7 and
g4 at the same time
so
the wind should be pretty easy
okay and it starts with move rook d4
king e5
oh interesting moment would you
take on oh i mean take on g4 of course
yeah it should be winning like
but uh
yeah he did
rook b4 was winning as well
but uh
yeah
uh
actually i should have given it to you
from uh from this position just to
uh let's see what happens if black
defends more stubborn like
well
then
it's pretty clear what happens here we
go here
and
okay what do you think the winners
no it's too easy you just go on rook b6
the bishop cannot move
and then king goes to the other side if
king goes to f5 it goes to h4 and you go
to h5 then f4 yeah it's just like
it's not even a problem so
serper played king e5 and then
well rook takes g4 won it
and
let's see what else left
guillermo chichen okay that would be
uh we're going to be on the black side
so just one second with board
it's more like a puzzle already than uh
real
so interesting rook and knight and three
and three on the same
on the same side which gives this
defendant side like a
pretty good
chances
okay to survive so you've got to be
careful and
very good technique demonstrated by
michal cheshan
okay
is it
oh
yeah
how do you win this one
yep
correct okay
so no rook takes you to
after what we did tonight is not a
complicated move right it's pretty
obvious but uh
did you really know that in order to win
like this
position it all comes to rook sacrifice
and there you can't win it otherwise
yeah
that's um
that that's it that's what you're
looking for that that's the technique of
converting the advantage so but it's at
the core at the final moment it will be
rook sacrifice and convert and
conversion into
win and pawn ending
okay
so
let's see what else left
yeah that's the
mchaltison beref okay
this is a puzzle already on black to
move what would you do
we're looking at the position from the
black side by the way yeah so
it's our move
um
yep you see how easy it is when you know
um
it is rook g4 when it moves
and
no that's it the pawn ending there is
nothing really to calculate and
after h4 is falling there's no defense
okay
our next one is
so
it's a
women world cup and 2012.
was it the final match or not no it
wasn't the final match but ron dufay
uh went on to the final
match of that world cup and where she
lost
okay
and then after that she went to
pittsburgh okay the
my city my hometown and when she
graduated carnegie mellon in the
accounting she
did like you know
six-year accounting degree and
now she's somewhere around seattle
like uh
the corporate job okay
second uh
final of the women world cup and well
unfortunately
another one with chess
all right anyways uh we're gonna be
looking
on a white side
it's pretty interesting game
real it's totally worth it of the world
cup okay
winning
winning
so no hesitation
the exchange in bishops
not white is not trying to win it with
all the pieces on the board exchanging
bishops
and then
we already know how this won right we're
improving our king
to towards like uh
the maximum
and we're looking uh into
liquidation until upon ending
so f4 can guff two
all right
and
all right white to move
now you know everything how do you win
this
rook c7 king is six yeah
rook takes takes and
are you sure you win in the opposition
okay let's see what happens if we do it
like uh
kinda
straightforward rook c7
okay
um king island so we take
takes
uh kindy five so we technically we want
the opposition the problem is
it's not really helped us because black
restores it right here right
and
if we can get the same position with
white to move yeah would be winning but
it's
so
it's a little a little bit trickier than
that but not by much
okay
so let's see
again when you know what you're looking
for
it's
fairly easy
can d5 first
king f6
and now
now rook takes yeah so
not directly but kin d5 first and only
after knight f6 we take
see
so it comes to a simple
end game and black resigned because
opposition is one
king of faith king is six and king here
king e8
and no the rest is a pretty trivial okay
so
this is
this is how the conversion works and uh
even
in the end game as simple as this one
but no rush when you're doing it the
rule number one no rush so rook c7 and
tech
will be a draw but king d5 and sacrifice
on f6 wins so you always have to
like recheck it twice because once you
sacrifice the rook and it's
there is no coming back there's i mean
you should be like hundred percent
and i think
the next one will be the last example
no it's still not
okay well
let's skip this one then
let's go to the next
yep because intel will manage philly
and
loading
previous game
no
load next game
this is also example from the
dresden olympiad
top women
russia versus georgia
black sacrifice and exchange
and compensation is overwhelming but for
some reason
it was overwhelming yeah not anymore so
take stakes
it's pretty good technique white
demonstrated in this game so again we're
gonna come to uh
a position in question
so king 7 no for those who defend in
this position for like uh
the king g 7 already a step in the wrong
direction if black would understand what
he's doing he would play d3 and just
like extend diagonal for the bishop and
forget this pawn on d4 will be lost
but
just play d3 king g7 and
i think it's just a draw
okay
well
black was trying to to defend it with
and then after
yeah and this is already lost so
g5
so how do you win it
no okay well since we know we all know
like what we're talking about skin g4
here right and again no hesitation
uh if this if the black pawn was not on
d4 and
black had the bishops who could go along
the diagonal back and forth there's
nothing white can do there's no physical
way that the king can go to f70
but this is just an easy win
right because white won
a distant opposition and no now just got
to be careful
so this is the simplest one right
the opposition and when already like
here here here and just come picking up
the pawn now because the pawn is on the
sixth rank it just really doesn't matter
where the kings are
so
no of course no rush from here but white
one in opposition and like
it's the winning one
okay
uh
well apparently it was not the last one
there was one more
so i'm sorry just like let's do it
arabica
okay
yeah it's a world uh juniors 2013.
now garage cannon is a clear
candidate to be a
next woman world champion
uh nor arabic is a
one of those
super strong georgian women
and they played at the wall juniors
okay
exchange so looks like a pretty good
compensation uh i'm sure it was a
compass it looked overwhelming for black
and maybe it was black who was playing
for a win here
but
gayatri cannot grab the initiative
somewhere around here she forced the tuk
sang
and won the f point so how was it i
don't
oh yeah somewhere around here
right black has no moves so it took
swank
king cannot move i'll play h7 bishop
cannot move lose the pawn so black is
forced to trade this one for that one
now in the same situation as before
like uh
how do you win this one right
you can get five here bishop d5
yeah
and
this one is a little bit
fancier because we need to calculate but
unfortunately
we don't have that much time and uh
so
i'll just show you like the end of this
game like how it ended
so to trunk takes
and come into
this position and she took
i don't remember was a mistake or
i think it was a mistake but uh okay ken
g4 king of three
yeah this is an interesting moment so
king d5
here we go
yeah no that just lost so
how was it
here we go 10
10 10
oh yeah okay
here the black made it so okay yeah now
i remember i forgot what it was so uh
taking on e4 was uh was a mistake here
she just miscalculated the pawn ending
she had to wait a little bit there was a
nice win but uh
i forgot what it was i think it started
with something rook b3 some kind of it
looks fine
and
she miscalculated the pawn ending but at
this point
black
did something out of this world like how
bad just like
uh
black played king d5 probably completely
forgot about this move
that's my guess so what happened
so instead
i
should have just done
this right
no it's it's lost c6 takes takes then
this form comes with
[Music]
how is it so is it a
where should be a kink when c6 is played
oh
yeah king should be on d4 right so
that's
here and instead of king c4 right
this one ken d4 and that should be a
draw right so it takes no it takes is an
easy draw so c6 takes
takes here we go
right this is a draw we're all just
coming in
so
instead black
that was correct and here she made like
a double question mark with played king
c4
so instead king d4 that's what uh
gary can i miscalculate it when she uh
sacrificed the rook
and position was a drone no instead the
georgian girl played the
king c4 now and after c6 takes and this
one a pawn was
so this is like a key moment where you
can uh
make a mistake uh yeah i don't want to
bother you with like uh
uh how undertook swank white wins this
and i
mean sacrifices on e4 and much better
version of it
but
that's it that's
i hope it was helpful
capablanca rule just when you're
converting an extra exchange in a lot of
those technical end games
that's the first thing you're looking
for for possibility to sacrifice it and
liquidate into winning pawn ending
rather than just try to win with the
rakana board because it feels better
right okay
um that's it that's uh the end of my
lecture today as thanks
to
russian magazine 64 that provided
materials for that
uh there was a reason why fisher
actually was subscriber to
a lot of russian magazines while he was
like
reading them while
taking a bass and stuff at least that's
what legend
urban legend says it tells us you know
what's happening okay and uh
thank you very much and i'll see you
next time
[Music]
you